speaking of Ron DeSantis vs Donald Trump
Fox News and Fox and Friends
specifically
continues to sort of take this approach
of softly and subtly pointing more in
the direction of this of DeSantis than
Donald Trump I'm gonna play for you this
is a couple minutes long but it's worth
looking at this in its in its totality
I'm going to play for you a couple
minute segment from this morning's Fox
and Friends in which Steve Ducey Ainsley
Earhart and Brian Kilmeade I'm reminding
myself of their names as I as I look at
them here uh spend a couple of minutes
with sort of erratic word salads really
unclear what the direction of this
segment was it was about polling it was
about these different things but
eventually they get to another subtle
push towards DeSantis and away from
Trump and the one they come up with
today is Biden would rather run against
Trump than DeSantis or put a different
way the way Brian Kilmeade puts it is
Biden is more scared of DeSantis than he
would be of trump and it's another way
to subtly suggest as Fox News has
increasingly been doing subtly they're
not abandoning Trump but they're subtly
pointing to DeSantis DeSantis would be
the stronger candidate because Biden
would rather run against Trump let's
let's really dig into this because
there's a lot here I understand that
people want to dismiss bad polls but his
response yesterday to Judy Woodruff was
yeah 50 people on a cell phone saying
they're unhappy about the direction of
the country we don't really care about
that okay if your polls were good if
they were fine you'd be like the polls
show people improve of the economy was
referring to the fact is that most
people say 50 percent in the Glasgow
poll 50 say they are worse off this year
than last year and 70 percent uh
believed they were heading in the wrong
direction the country said they're
living paycheck to paycheck inflation
gas prices are up and he could Now
understand that two-thirds of the
country living paycheck to paycheck
isn't a new thing four years ago I told
you and remember who was president then
that something like half of Americans
would need to borrow money if they got
hit with an unexpected 400 expense a lot
of this stuff isn't new for a long time
many Americans have felt the countries
going in the wrong direction but there
there you can see that they're sort of
struggling to come up with a story and
eventually the story they shift to is
Biden is more scared of uh DeSantis than
he is of trump they're down they're up
from where they were when he took off
it's just crazy and so the president is
going to Tampa today this is the second
time in two months uh the president or
the vice president have been down in
Florida why is that is it because
DeSantis they're worried about that it
could be Senior Communities too uh well
what they're trying to do is uh they're
exactly uh DeSantis Democratic
strategists expect the president to set
the stage for a re-election and draw
contrast with Ron DeSantis you know he's
drawn uh comparisons to Donald Trump in
the past but now it looks and you're
speaking of polls you see these polls in
Ron DeSantis is surging it's like okay
forget about Trump for right now let's
uh let's go ahead and go down to where
Ron DeSantis is and talk about saving
all this stuff Florida was a purple
State and now it's completely red we saw
that 19 points uh Rhonda Santos won in a
landslide so it'll be interesting to see
they're trying to save Florida in their
minds and bring it back well I think
that he's got a he's got a message in
the area that he feels as though is
experiencing good Economic Times number
one number two seniors he wants to
continue to harp on that uh inaccurate
message that Republicans want to get rid
of in Sunset men Medicare and Social
Security and I'll add something else as
good as Ron DeSantis is doing even
though he's getting a pack together it
looks like he's going to run Donald
Trump's still beating him uh in most
polls and in fact I think he's a solid
second but Trump's still up front and I
just wonder on some level if President
Biden rather have Trump than than to say
well so there it is would Biden prefer
Trump rather than DeSantis and so this
is part of the they have built uh an
ejector seat so to speak so that if it
comes to it that Donald Trump is not the
nominee they want to get away from Trump
as quickly as possible and they would
rather move Beyond Trump and go to
DeSantis but they can't just bail
altogether because Trump indeed might be
the nominee and if Trump is the nominee
he might indeed be the president again
and Fox News doesn't want to lose access
but this is now like the sixth or
seventh sort of segment that we've seen
from Fox and Friends where they're
either doing the man on the street
interviews where they happen to bump
into all Republicans who want DeSantis
over Trump uh or they're talking about
polling or whatever the case may be they
are continuing the subtle push away from
Trump and towards DeSantis what exactly
their motivation is you know some say
it's because Rupert Murdoch personally
really doesn't like Trump others say
it's because they see the writing on the
wall or it would be better for them for
this that the other thing I don't really
know what the answer is I don't think
it's completely clear and it may be
different for different people at Fox
News but they are setting themselves up
to be right in there with a hypothetical
DeSantis nominee or DeSantis
Administration but they've got to play
it safe and so this is the sort of stuff
that they're doing what do you believe
is fox's motivation and end game let me
know info davidpackman.com or leave a
comment if you're watching on YouTube or
Facebook or Instagram will take a very
quick break and much more coming up
after this